pas d'accent là et je veux que les têtes
d'affiché soit visible le metteur en
scène dominic champagne a réuni une
distribution de rêve pour lancer un
nouveau mouvement écologiste à l'avant
scène yvon deschamps claude béland et
janette bertrand font partie des 500
premiers artistes à avoir signé le pacte
pour la transition
j'ai des amis artistes jeta s'est engagé
dans l'idée aussi depuis quelques années
pour avoir une certaine crédibilité
auprès de vedettes sont beaucoup plus
populaires que moi alors je les appelle
en disant je pense qu'il faut aussi le
faire n'a pas le pacte pour la
transition et un appel à réduire
individuellement notre empreinte
écologique
cet engagement ont pu le signer sur le
site internet le pacte points c'est à
qui nous propose entre autres de
diminuer notre consommation de pétrole
et de sensibiliser les gens autour de
nous à la cause environnementale
je sens qu'il faut que je laisse quelque
chose à mes enfants mais j'ai huit
petits-enfants cinq arrières petites
filles dans quelle planète ils vont
vivre
le pacte a convié des scientifiques pour
nous rappeler qu'il est minuit moins une
en matière d'environnement il ya urgence
très urgente
on a une dizaine d'années est réellement
pour avoir amorcé une transition
énergétique au niveau planétaire
et c'est sans équivoque de leur propre
aveu des signataires du pacte pour la
transition ont du travail à faire pour
respecter leurs engagements sur les
plateaux tournage et énormément de
gaspillage qui je m'engage aussi à faire
en sorte que plus de bouteille donc plus
de couverts sur les tasses à café que te
montre à une sa gourde
j'ai certaines améliorations faire je
vais fumer placement aussi ça a été fait
depuis longtemps
en plus de convaincre les citoyens
dominic champagne veut convaincre les
politiciens et confondre les sceptiques
j'ai répondu hier à un troll qui dit bon
encore les artistes qui s'enveloppe dans
leurs vertus jeudi écoute moi si tu veux
on va se rencontrer on va se parler
le pacte pour la transition compte
recueillir un million de signatures et
inciter les citoyens à participer à la
grande marche pour l'environnement qui
aura du sandia montréal ici louis
philippe ouimet
radio-canada m'ont rien